c'est que vous êtes tous dingues de vos
téléphones portables plein
d'applications dessus ce que faisaient
les applications de messagerie pas dire
sur wii bon arrêtez vous n'avez pas
d'applications de messagerie ne sais pas
ce que je sais que vous mentez
et parce que je vous pose cette question
parce que dans le soir 3 national on a
appris qu'une très célèbre application
de messagerie avait été piratée tremblay
en rendant plus d'un milliard de
téléphones portables vulnérables dont
celui de karni turbide on sait qu'il ya
dedans et je peux vous dire c'est très
joli je ne regarde il suffit d'un appel
manqué pour que l'application propriété
de facebook soit piraté des hackers
auraient ciblé des milliers de comptes
pour espionner le téléphone de leurs
propriétaires
il s'agirait d'une société de
cybersurveillance israélienne sap est
une messagerie omniprésente elle
fonctionne même quand elle est éteinte
et ses prérogatives sont très larges
comme utiliser votre caméra à votre
indiquent ils
l'autorité de protection des données
européenne demande à tous les
utilisateurs de mettre leurs
applications à jour alors je sais que
tout le monde se fiche de ce qui est
dans mes conversations whatsapp mais du
coup j'ai mis à jour quand même en me
disant on ne sait jamais est ce que vous
en pensez caroline ben moi j'ai fait
comme vous vous sauf qu'à la différence
c'est que moi je pense que personne ne
s'en fou rire face aux super intéressant
non mais attendez je sais pas pour moi
le téléphone portable c'est vraiment le
journal intime 2.0 c'est à dire que
c'est le truc ultime phase avait des
choses à cacher mais j'ai rien à cacher
mais j'écris mais on s'est dit des
choses après parfois je je je n'ai plus
que j'ai écrit voilà ya toujours des
petites photos qui traîne à droite à
gauche d'emilie loupé n'avais pas envie
qu'on aille voir ce qu'elle fait à deux
heures du matin l'occasion de vous avez
foulé les choses comme ça donc oui je
flippe même si je pense que ça n'est pas
forcément adressé non je trouve que de
cette façon
effectivement on a une sorte de mouchard
sous les yeux vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre et qu'on n'est pas allé
jusqu'à désinstaller l'application comme
hergé fait maintenant j'ai la chance on
peut citer monde a bien travaillé suis
très angoissé parce que je fais partie
de ces personnes qui vont aux toilettes
avec leur téléphone portable donc elle
rappelant parce que j'aurai vraiment
peur que le téléphone film à mon insu et
là il y aura des découvertes
extraordinaires croyez vraiment qu'il ya
des gens qui attendent
soyez aux toilettes pour vous filmez
vous savez moi c'est là c'était
merveilles du monde non